In 2017,
it'll be 70 years since India broke off
from the British empire and became an
independent country,
which is today actually the largest
democracy in the world.
In these 70 years,
India has managed to implement a
political system with more than 1000
parties and high female participation.
That is totally unprecedented in such a
poor
country.
Of course,
we should probably wait before we pop
the champagne because we can't exactly
say that these 70 years of independence
have gone brilliantly in this gigantic
country of more than one point 2
billion.
What's the equality?
A terrible cost system and many,
many problems with women's rights have
continued to shake this nation.
That's for wars with Pakistan,
which has become something of a arch
enemy.
Yeah,
but if you really want to know why we
might claim that India can't be proud of
the last 70 years.
Well,
we only need to compare this country's
evolution with that of China Sea.
When Dung shopping launched his policy
to open up China to the world and change
the economic model back in the 19
eighties,
the sizes of these two economic giants.
China and India,
they were similar in 2016.
However,
the China's GDP,
it was five times higher.
I mean,
just check out this
graph
and not only that,
these differences repeats in practically
every statistic,
social and economic and Tobias,
another example.
Well,
while China's illiteracy rate affects
less than four percent of the population
in China,
almost a one out of every three people
can't read or write.
Considering all this,
we should almost reached the conclusion
that the only good thing that this
country has achieved,
it hasn't been.
It's democracy,
right?
Just a second,
because it seems that this poverty and
injustice is beginning to shift for
experts,
so betting that the 21st century will be
above all India century.
That is to say that in the next few
decades,
we'll witness how this country emerges
from the developing world to become an
economic superpower.
Many companies such as Amazon and apple
already betting on this transformation,
ends up paying close attention to this
huge market.
They understand that if expectations are
mess in the next few years,
we could see one of the biggest business
opportunities in history.
Great,
and it's not just companies,
the Deli government's own expectations
are so high that they expect this
country's transformation to be at least
as impressive as that of China in the
coming decades.
For this reason,
they want to be prepared.
They are contemplating,
for example,
building 250 airports,
six new macro reports,
and creating more than $150,
million new and accessible homes in the
next 10 years.
In other words,
everything indicates that we may see
India's takeoff,
which,
well,
that's got to be a good thing,
right?
Well,
do you keep one thing in mind and that
is the Beijing doesn't like this.
They don't like it at all.
Crust and resentment
is India's main trading partner.
However,
despite this,
Chinese authorities look at India's
growing economic,
political,
and military capacity with a lot of
distrust.
This is because this is a time when
China wants to gain political influence
and this change in India.
It doesn't suit them at all.
India is perhaps the only country in
Asia with enough potential to offset
China's political power in the region.
After all,
we're talking about what will soon be
the most populated country on earth and
there's even some analysts who confirmed
that maybe this has already happened,
but India has already surpassed China in
terms of population size,
but it isn't only that because of the
one child policy that affected China for
so many years,
India's population has and will have
more young people and less elderly
people,
which is quite a significant advantage
given these circumstances.
It's easy to understand Beijing's
distrust of India.
Then you agree India has the fastest
growing economy in the world.
We hope we're going to be catching it
very soon in terms of percentage
increase.
I have to tell you that we're working on
it now.
Don't think that this feeling only
exists in political officers,
not at all.
In fact,
this growing rivalry is actually also
reflected on the streets.
Consider the following data.
According to a survey published in 2016
by the Pew Research Center that only one
in four Chinese people have a favorable
opinion of India and in India things are
not more encouraging.
Seven out of every 10 are worried about
Beijing's military drive and believe
that China's economic influence is
hurting them.
In other words,
it seems that both China and India as
populations know that their neighbors
are also.
They're great
rivals.
In any case,
curiously,
it must be said that despite all of this
rivalry,
Bollywood is actually quite popular in
China.
This summer we saw how dangle and Indian
blockbuster swept the Chinese box office
and it became one of the highest
grossing films in China of all time and
well,
as you might imagine,
this is something that the government in
Beijing,
they do really like that much in terms
of soft power.
India has done better than China,
although India's economy is not as
developed.
They've put a huge emphasis on promoting
their culture.
John Jean Cui,
director of the Southeast Asian Research
Institute at Peking University.
Well anyway,
it would be great if all tensions
occurred in let's see,
such a peaceful way,
but unfortunately that is not the case.
Disputes in is while everyone was
looking at Pyong Yang and the North
Korean nuclear crisis occupied every
front page,
another political crisis when it was
about to explode,
happens in the Himalayas more than 4,000
meters above sea level in one of the
most remote places on earth.
That dockland plateau in this place
between June and August,
one of the most serious political crises
between China and India in the last 55
years occurred when Chinese troops
invaded northern India.
See,
on June the eighth,
2017,
a squad of Chinese border guards into
construction team entered the territory
that is disputed between China and the
small closed kingdom of time.
That is the country with the highest
gross national happiness.
Yes,
that is something.
We will certainly be discussing it a
video someday,
but well,
the fact is that the Chinese unit's
destroyed.
Several bunkers owned by the butan royal
army,
and they began to build a road.
However,
since Bhutan's protection has been in
India,
Sam,
since the 19 forties,
Indian troops arrived on June the 16th
and blocked the roads construction so
far a pretty typical border conflict.
However,
the tensions,
they didn't dilute.
They actually increased as the
discussions between Beijing and New
Delhi.
Oh,
they became quite tense.
Chinese state media began to threaten
the Indian government with serious
consequences.
China and India are dangerously close to
military conflict in the Himalayas out
at this point,
you might be wondering,
well,
why on earth was a land that is
practically frozen for most of the year
given such importance?
On the one hand,
it seems that Xi Jinping's governments
wanted to test India and punish them for
well,
a bunch of things for that relationship
with the Dalai Lama and with Tibet for
that growing ties with Washington for
their relations with Pakistan and so on
and so with regard to India because
China's controlling this area with its
military presence in new road would put
China within a stone's throw of the
Siliguri corridor and narrow strip of
land is considered strategic because it
connects seven of the states of
northeast India with the rest of the
country.
This is something you'd see well on
this.
It's above all.
Beyond the tactical issues,
there's another important reason.
The same reason why China wanted to test
India and you're going to see what I'm
talking about in just a minute.
Practice that finally on August the 28th
after many threats and a lot of tension,
both sides agreed to withdraw their
troops and return to the starting points
of this entire political muscle.
Of course years ago,
both powers rivalry.
It wasn't as obvious as it is now,
but of course let's not fool ourselves
the doc cam,
so it's.
Well,
it's the least of it.
I'm not just saying this because of the
more than 3000 kilometers of border that
have territorial disputes between China
and India that are many,
many more a national strategy given them
the possible emergence of India as a
superpower at the Chinese governments
have adopted a strategy and that's just
around it and yeah,
it's pretty much exactly what it sounds
like.
In recent years,
China has tightened its ties with
Pakistan in exchange for $60,
billion dollars in infrastructure,
especially to connect both countries,
including a strategic board in China,
will operate until at least the year 20.
Fifteen,
on the other hand is a Chinese
government company has taken control of
Hambantota port in Sri Lanka,
a country with which Beijing is also
strengthening its political ties
regarding Bangladesh.
China has become the most important arm
supplier.
Last year they sold them to submarines
and finally there's an a poll which is
greatly improved its relationship with
China off to a political conflict in
2015 with New Delhi.
Now,
well let's have a look at it.
You see India is surrounded crisis.
It was simply nothing more than a move
in a chess game and this is a chess game
in which China has the economic capacity
under the money to make friends very
easily.
Of course,
the fact that China's military
superiority over India is overwhelming.
Well,
that's also very helpful.
So a question that might arise after all
of this is,
well,
what's India's bet?
Or rather what's their realistic
response as well?
That response,
it basically comes in three words and
those three words aren't the United
States.
Yeah,
you heard it in recent years,
relations between the United States and
India have become pretty close seat
between 2009 and 2016 bilateral trade
has doubled and the sale of military
equipment from the United States to
India has multiplied by 50 years.
In fact,
everything indicates that India is going
to replace that old mig.
Twenty one with a mega contracts have
newly manufactured f six teams,
200 of them,
and if this is confirmed,
Lockheed Martin's intention,
the manufacturer with pentagons approval
of course,
is to transfer this plane's worldwide.
Production from Texas to India are
pretty unbeatable way to strengthen
alliances,
don't you think?
Well,
now we can better understand not only
China and India's tense relationship,
but also for example,
the US is new hard strategy towards
Pakistan,
which we discussed in our previous video
about Afghanistan
as of course
all of this starts based on a premise
that India will emulate the economic
success that China has achieved in
recent decades.
Narendra Modi,
the popular Indian Prime Minister of
whom we already talked about is leading
many changes,
but not as many as the country needs,
but that is a discussion we can be for
another day and now we want to know,
do you think China will succeed in
beating India?
Well,
please do leave your comments in the
comment section below and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also,
do not forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine as well.
If you look for something else to watch,
please do check out my brand new channel
biographics where we do biographies of
notable people from the past and the
present,
and as always,
thank you for watching.